let's say everybody's selling banana you
can't say i'm
a 5x better banana you instead you
should come out and say i'm an apple
and not everybody's gonna want your
apple but a hundred percent of the
people who prefer apples are gonna want
what you have
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right uh yeah sean this um i i was
playing this
podcast pretty good um how'd you feel
um it was good it was like we showed up
no no context
like what are we going to talk about do
i need to do i need to talk about
bitcoin do i need to have something
smart to say about bitcoin because i
kind of just
you know i believe i buy i hold
right i'm like a monkey in this space
i'm not like you know one of these
experts
but um but we talked about solo biggest
solo capitalist
solopreneur and uh some of the different
kind of like things around that so i
thought i thought it was
actually pretty good conversation ben
was there and he was like i liked this
one because i feel like everything you
said in this was
something new that i had never heard you
say before he's like whereas you know
once you listen to somebody for like
hundreds of hours
you kind of hear the same greatest hits
over and over again he's like this felt
like new stuff
speaking of listening to us for hundreds
of hours or listening to you at least we
had a good episode we just
interviewed this guy named mike maples
mike was pretty cool so mike
is a little under the radar but he
started this thing called floodgate
which is a really big venture capital
firm
but really fascinating guy what what all
have they done they've done
lyft twitch um twitter
crews octa which is like a giant
enterprise company that's public
so yeah a bunch of bunch of big winners
that he was an investor in pretty early
considered um one of the best venture
capital firms there is so
real insightful guy he kind of had a
hint of biology a little bit
uh i mean he was like real high iq i've
been using the word high functioning
um he's like a real high functioning he
was a high functioning southerner right
he had this disarming way of talking
because he's got this you know kind of
like
is this southern or midwestern accent
yeah and uh
you know very very relatable likable guy
but then the things he was saying
each one was like you know like sort of
a bullet into you know
of an idea of an insight and he
definitely had like a few refined ideas
of
where he thinks the puck is going and i
appreciate that i like that he gave us
basically these four waves he's like
you know i believe these four
inflections are happening right now and
that's going to create a bunch of
opportunity
and that's what i look for is like how
is the world changing
and then what's what's going to be new
because of these inflection points
yeah i was taking notes the four things
are blockchain cloud office
american x the cloud culture for
consumers so those are like the four
things and
we went into like we didn't actually go
into each one entirely but he talked a
little bit about each one and we delved
uh we went deep into cloud office and he
talked about the opportunities there
i thought it was great what do you think
i loved it i loved the way he
had some phrases for things i thought at
the beginning he was like a little bit
too intellectual for me i was like okay
wait where do i go with this
but um it was interesting but i didn't
know how to attach it to like
a concrete idea and then i thought about
you know that was maybe the first 25
and then the next 75 i thought were
fantastic where
um yeah it came down to earth and also
he has these
this is kind of amazing way of talking
i'm kind of jealous dude
you are like that i know but i i because
i like because i try to be like that
when i see somebody who's really good at
it i'm like oh you're good at this
thing
most people don't even care about this
thing he had these little phrases
coined terms for either himself or his
fund or his philosophy or his mental
models
and uh you know he'd be like you know
startup is like a jazz band not a
marching band
and then he would explain the analogy
and then he was like he was like
i want people to choose not compare
which is
hard to understand but once he explains
it then it's like oh that's actually a
wonderful
mental framework it's like that kanye
song where it's like what does it mean
it's like i don't know what it means but
it sounds provocative
and that's how i felt with a lot of his
things was like effort i was like and
immediately interested i leaned in when
he would say one of those phrases
even though my brain hadn't figured out
exactly what it means yet and then he
would explain it
so anyways i thought it was really good
and super nice dude i really
thought he came you know he's so humble
uh and and very likable so i don't know
great episode i i liked him a lot
i agree and he offered to come back i
couldn't tell if
like when guys are being nice i'm like
well if you have time let's just keep
going
all right i couldn't tell if he was
being kind we'll have to have him back
on uh
he was awesome right uh how did you feel
about uh
when you hit him up for some intros
there was that smooth
uh i thought it was pretty smooth yeah
you gave him the opportunity to be a
hero and if not
it was totally okay yeah i asked him
i'm gonna start asking every guest that
the the question i'm gonna start asking
is
uh who do you think would be an awesome
guess like who would be good for those
podcasts and then uh
what do you think's the best way to get
in touch with them right and then they
have the opportunity to be like yeah
just
reach out he's a nice guy or yeah let me
just shoot him a note right now i'll
tell him uh i'll intro you guys right
i thought that was a great angle i know
i wanted to call it out because people
are listening
uh they get this sort of behind the
scenes of
as i heard you say it i was like oh
smooth
smooth guy sam going for the intro
we didn't get the kill on this time but
uh we got
i i feel as though i've we've built
enough rapport with him i can out email
mike and maybe he'll help he'll hook it
up but
yeah he did a good job there we go so
mike do you um
i was connected to you because my friend
my good friend noah kagan was like
you gotta holler at this guy he's pretty
interesting and i've known about you as
well
because tim ferriss um lived near me and
was a friend of mine
and he told me that he's like there's
like two people
or three people whose advice i listen to
when it comes to investing
one is naval the founder of angellist
who
is scott belski who started the hands
and is now
probably going to be the ceo of adobe
and three
was you yeah okay and i was like that's
kind of interesting you know i
i have not really heard of mike too much
you know you're kind of you kind of you
kind of keep a
a low profile and i looked it up and so
you started floodgate which eventually
you guys have messed it in like twitter
twitch
lyft all types of amazing stuff but we
so we have this podcast show tonight
it's pretty popular um you know millions
of people listen and
all we do is just brainstorm interesting
ideas and so we thought
you know we got to get you on to come
and talk about some stuff and so here we
are
let's give it a shot why not thanks for
having me and by the way i've listened
to your podcast
uh a bunch of times i remember the the
in the episode with the with kevin
systrom from instagram
is okay one of my favorite ones so uh
what's the exact thing
is starting starting greatness or
starting starting greatness yeah
starting greatness and it's it's kind of
a labor of love you know i
uh uh some of the people that work at
floodgate occasionally we'd have some
hallway conversation or in a meeting
they're like dude i wish we could have
recorded that
right so so in many ways the the guests
not only help with the the content but
but we're trying to
help help the some of the key ideas of
starting greatness come alive through
the voices of the guests
because i think there are some some
counter-intuitive lessons of starting a
great startup that are
not obvious to people right and you have
a you have a good voice and then b
your intros are great on the pod you uh
it always has like i don't know how much
time you spend on that but
uh the intros are great compared to us
we put we're sort of famous for
we barely do an intro like you'll be 10
minutes in and be like who the hell is
this guest
and then um you know sometimes at the
end we do the
sort of irish goodbye where we're like
okay that's it
we just sort of like we end it we go
about our day and so people have like
started making fun of us making shirts
about
the the irish goodbye because they're
like dude i also hate saying goodbyes
it's
it's you know i hate the unwind of a
conversation i like how you guys just
leave
and and so that's that's kind of our
thing um
but what we want i guess i want to start
with we could talk about kind of like
all the great stuff you've invested in
uh but i guess
i'm more curious about what's get what's
got you excited now what space is
what trends are you seeing where you're
like huh i don't fully
i don't fully know what's there but uh
there's enough there for me to be
interested
yeah and it might be kind of a good
segue into how i think about
what the next big thing will be because
there's this there's this thing that i
say to founders which is very encounter
it's very counterintuitive i say if you
want to start a great startup
don't try to think of a startup and uh
the reason for that
is that great startup founders are like
time travelers and they they
get out of the present and they
visualize different
futures that are a breakthrough that
break free from the present
and when you try to think of a startup
right now
you tend to orient yourself in the world
of the present and so you tend to come
up with incremental conventional ideas
rather than
breakthrough ideas that sort of change
the arc of the present to a different
future
and so um and that gets the areas that
i'm interested in so what i what i
encourage founders to think about are
what are the inflections
what are the waves of change they're
going to be so massive
that uh it's gonna allow an entrepreneur
to change the subject
about the future because on some level
these waves
are the gathering power it's like all
the power of the ocean when you surf
uh you you gotta catch the right wave to
have a chance to do great things
and uh it's these waves or these
inflections
they allow the entrepreneur to wage
asymmetric warfare
on the present only with big inflections
does an entrepreneur go from being
uh disadvantaged to incumbents to having
a fundamental advantage
vis-a-vis incumbents and so then in
terms of the areas that i'm interested
in
i tend to go with the inflections and so
um
one inflection i'm interested in
obviously is uh the blockchains
uh with crypto uh i think that if i was
starting a startup today that's probably
where i would spend most of my time
another another area of interest for me
is um
the the transition from what i like to
call office culture to cloud culture
and so in the past the cloud was sort of
more of a delivery mechanism
uh and a business model for application
software
but now what we see happening is that um
the the you know microsoft office
literally is a metaphor of the office
and it's
files and memos and file drawers and
that's what our desktop looks like
but now people you know it's it's not
the editor
that matters as much anymore as the
comment system and the versioning it's
kind of more like
github meets knowledge work and so you
know when you
when you have cloud culture rather than
office culture you you can take
advantage of a lot of arbitrage time
arbitrage talent arbitrage
geography arbitrage you know that very
tim ferriss
you know we talked about him a little
bit earlier uh and then
the other thing that i'm interested in
is um
what i loosely refer to as america next
and so on some level i think that 2020
was the first real year of the 20th
century
or 21st century and why is that uh
i think that there were a lot of uh
issues that
uh people were paying lip service to uh
a lot of stagnation that people were
paying lip service to
and i think that 2020 helped people
understand
uh our military needs to become more
agile and more tech forward
that our research and drugs and drug
discovery that our ability to get
uh life-saving remedies to market faster
we need to take seriously there's just
you know china as a geopolitical
uh challenger and so as a result i think
that
um there and you know now people talk
about buildback better
but i just believe fundamentally the
united states the western world are
going to decide they need to invest for
real
in tech forward infrastructure and then
on the flip side of that they're going
to realize our infrastructure is
vulnerable to
cyber hackers and ransomware and things
like that whether it's organized by
rogue gangs or nation states so so those
are
i'd say those three areas plus also i'd
say
uh cloud culture applied to consumer
which some call the metaverse
but those are those are the main things
that i'm chasing right now and you know
obviously i have a lot of colleagues as
well at floodgates so we you know we go
after cyber security and
uh cloud infrastructure and other things
but the areas that i described are the
ones that i'm
most accurate most actively going after
for that cloud
office one what what products are you
looking at that excite you
yeah so i'll kind of give you an example
so um
one company i'm involved with is called
almanac and uh it allows
uh teams of people to create documents
but like if you think about it um
this has already happened in uh code and
in design
so in code you had github and in the
past you just had
code snippets that you shipped around
and had some version control
but github made code social and you
could branch and
fork and uh you know collaborate as a
team
at the center rather than as an
afterthought and then figma did the same
thing with design
right so figma and so so what what we
believe
is that in a world where talent can live
anywhere
in the world it's going to matter more
that you write things down and get
consensus and part of how you get
consensus is you have
a paradigm that's not office centric in
documentation but it's cloud-centric and
so
you know why shouldn't you just like
github be able to branch and merge and
fork
documents and be able to within that one
document know
every version of that document that
every ever existed and everybody's
and you know if somebody forks it and
uses it let's say it's an employee
handbook
if somebody uses it for their next
company why not want to know that as
well and so
uh but but that's just one of many
examples of where
i believe that in the future you're
going to have all these different
products that uh presuppose
that people will collaborate you know
what else do i think will happen i think
people will say
if it can go in the cloud it should if
it can be asynchronous it should
because if i put things in the cloud and
make them asynchronous i can take
advantage of all those different forms
of arbitrage to run my company better
whereas if i'm a meeting centric culture
i have to be in the room where it
happened
when a decision got made and i just
think that that's an outmoded way of
thinking about things in today's world
what so sean and i are similar
or almost the same age we or we are the
same age we um
like when we started work i mean we use
google docs
right away but you're a little bit older
than us and
like that would that was a you probably
didn't i mean that was kind of kind of
interesting to you right when that
when that first came around so when you
say like what needs to be in the cloud
in my head i'm like wait are you kidding
me isn't
everything already like that what
specifically are
you for example there's there's startups
that are doing like
virtual office so they're like great
everybody's remote you have all these
advantages remote what do you miss out
on you miss out on being able to
socialize and get to know each other and
build trust
outside of the you know the water cooler
the what you the conversations that used
to happen in the break room
so there's these crazy startups that are
saying basically like like online town
and stuff like that that are like
here's a virtual office you can
literally walk around you can bump into
people
i don't know if any of these work right
but they're like taking stabs at
trying to move the like physical office
into the cloud too sam so it's not just
docs are in the cloud
but hanging out is in the cloud right
co-workers in the hallways in the cloud
yeah and
the problem with most cloud offerings
today is that they're basically
re-hosted
office culture right so like zoom zoom
is a meeting but it's a meeting online
it's not like it's asynchronous in any
way
it's not it you're just re-hosting the
meeting rather than
redefining how work happens now with
zoom you can take advantage of
geography arbitrage i suppose so that is
a good thing but you're not able to take
advantage of
time and talent arbitrage as easily but
like
like what i what i believe ends up
happening at the limit is in
in office culture everybody has a job
description
and uh and what i think in cloud culture
you know
people have already talked about this
but this idea of uh jobs to be done
theory
and so like when you think about it all
of us don't just have one job
all of us do a whole bunch of jobs like
if you take even a very
simple example let's say that i work at
a flower shop
i might type things into the computer to
manage customer records i might take
reservations and orders i might some
parts of the day
arrange the flowers well when you really
think about it
the principle of comparative advantage
would suggest
that any parts of that any of those jobs
to be done that could be done
asynchronously or in the cloud you
should try to do that if you can
because then you could take advantage of
labor arbitrage time arbitrage and
geography arbitrage
and then if i'm a great flower arranger
that's what i should be spending my time
on is the thing that i'm really good at
and so
what i think cloud culture lets people
do at the limit is
um broadcast their comparative advantage
to the world
and uh get paid by the network for
giving the network what it wants
so i think that it'll you know the
reason i call it cloud culture as well
is who says everybody has to work at a
company
right like people said that robots are
gonna eat the jobs
but i think that's precisely the
opposite of what's true i think that
software is going to reduce the need for
people to think they need to work at
companies
because it's going to all the things i
would have had to possess
to to have a job i'm not gonna need
those things anymore
uh by working at a company i'm gonna be
able to have all those things in
software
on my own and so i think more and more
people are gonna
people are gonna realize that really
there is a
uh aggregate of jobs that people do
and all of them could be thought of as
like almost like a derivative that can
be
assembled in different ways and then
move to the cloud or
you know let you specialize and i think
that that'll over time
change the fundamental culture of how
teams work
and tell me if i misunderstand this but
i think one thing that you just said in
there
is that this idea that one person
belongs to one firm
is potentially now an outdated and uh
you know sub-optimal
idea that instead you said like a user
basically contributes to the network and
gets paid for that contribution to the
network and so
one person might belong to multiple
firms
and you know firm might change so so
what does that look like you're the time
traveler
yes let's say we fast forward 10 years
uh smart guy like me
how does my like today you know my
company got acquired by twitch i got a
day job at twitch
uh you know great that's that's you know
something i do
and i you know before code thanks for
your efforts there by the way i mean we
we monetized that a little while ago but
thanks for your efforts
of course anything i can do for you by
the way uh a vc is saying we monetize
that is a wonder that that's a really
cool flex
i'm gonna i'm gonna feel that so okay
so then what 10 years from now so like
maybe maybe i should
start from the beginning there so what
do i think is really happening
right that underlies all my investing i
basically believe that
starting around 1850 we had
centralized means of production mass
distribution
mass production and what that allowed us
to do is to create the modern
corporation but in
1870 there was no accounting there were
no org charts
none of this stuff that we take for
granted as a company really existed
but mass production and mass
distribution had a tendency to to
centralize things
because you got supply-side economies of
scale and mass distribution allows you
to
get things out to people i think what
started to happen
uh probably in the late 70s early 80s
with the microprocessor is now the
economy is animated by mass computation
and mass connectivity
and those two uh those two attributes
tend to decentralize the means of
production
and so you know i think we've moved from
river rouge plant for ford model ts to
personal 3d printers in the future
and i think we've moved from peak
centralization of three tv networks
in the late 50s early 60s to now anybody
can be their own publisher
or media company that goes direct and so
there's a a lot of very basic
assumptions we have about companies
that are just 150-year artifacts of time
like
somebody in 1820 wouldn't recognize a
normal company of today there weren't
there weren't any companies more than 20
people in the u.s you know in in 1820
hardly
maybe a few spinning looms with 100
people but so what i believe is now the
idea is
the the social contract between a person
and a big company
people assume that it's not gonna that
it's gonna persist i think it's gonna be
radically different so
in in the in the 1900s you know you had
uh people wanting to be at a company for
a very long time
and you had large country companies
because uh
the coordination advantages of having a
large organization at scale with
supply-side
economics was valid and created
abundance
then the same happened with the military
then the same thing happened with the
government
media all of our major institutions but
now i think the pendulum is
uh swinging in the other direction
towards um
a worldwide network where everybody on
the network every individual is a node
on that network
and every individual as a node on that
network
has a comparative advantage and they get
they get paid by the network when they
give the network what it wants
uh and that's true for money it's true
for jobs it's true for everything in my
view
are there examples of startups now that
are that are executing this
yeah so in the early days our
investments were in these pure play
networks
twitter twitch uh companies like that
what would it be
what do you mean pure play a pureplay
network would be
you're not really reimagining a part of
the economy
so like twitch was a whole new thing and
you could argue that twitter's had a big
impact on the media
but but that wasn't the thesis when we
invested but then we started to get
interested in this idea of well
perhaps every sector of the economy is
going to be reimagined around
um sort of the the the micro means
of production and so rather than
economies of scale it's going to be
local economies of algorithmic
computation
and networks that span the globe and so
why did we invest in lyft
lyft was a more modern way to think
about getting a ride than taxes
taxis are a command and control
tops-down dispatch-driven technology
lyft says hey riders and drivers can
advertise their presence in real time on
a network and algorithms will form
an ad-hoc connection so it's kind of
like this return of the invisible hand
and uh now all of a sudden the invisible
hand is done by algorithms rather than
uh you know kind of in the good old days
of people trading fur for musket or
something like that
but like it's it you know that's what we
see happening time and again
uh you know ohm connect is another uh
board i'm on
they're trying to uh create um
incentives for people to use less
electricity but but they're basically
applying the ideas of software-defined
networks to
uh subtracting energy that homes use
uh during certain times of the day and
so i believe that every
you know what is tesla really tesla is a
car company
that's animated by networked capitalism
not industrial capitalism
right they it's a software-defined car
that's updated over the air
it leverages machine learning it
leverages network effects with all the
sensors in the network to help it
self-drive better apple was a network
capitalist-centric phone compared to
like nokia
which thought we need to sell the best
widget and so in sector after sector of
our economy
the companies that are software defined
at their core
i believe software-defined
network-centric companies at their core
are going to keep winning
and they're going to keep displacing the
companies that think of
computers as the thing that you did to
make your industrial thing go
faster so you know burger king isn't a
software-defined network even though it
has computers
it uses computers to say how many
hamburgers did i sell today
but it doesn't use computers to reinvent
food in any fundamental way and the
companies that we're investing in are
companies that leverage network
capitalism to reimagine reinvent markets
from the beginning damn big idea i hope
that wasn't
that may be a little bit out there but
uh that's kind of it
it's such a big idea that it's hard to
how can i make this more practical for
myself and the listeners of someone
interested in this field yeah and so the
way i would say
to make it more practical if you're a
listener is the tendency is to say
uh what's my career path going to be but
through the lens
of the 20th century you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna make a progressive set of
steps and i'm gonna
uh you know i'm gonna get rewarded as i
do the things that
i seem to need to do in society but i
would argue that it's more important in
today's
world to figure out a what am i awesome
at or or
maybe not even one of my the best in the
world at but what is my
what am i best at among all other things
i'm good at what am i best at
and then what does the world value and
then
what am i passionate about and it's like
the intersection of that
set of things is where you want to
develop your talents because
over time that's where your comparative
advantage will be the highest
and that is where the network will pay
you the most for contributing to the
network
but i think sometimes it's useful to not
think of not just
what company do i want to join or what
set of companies should i join my career
instead you should say
the entire world is a network everybody
is a node in that network
how can i be the best version of myself
as a node on that network how can i
create the most possible value for that
network so that i'll
get recognized by it and pay paid for
the value that i deliver
so how do you do that so let's say let's
take you for example so let's say you
look at the world this way as it's a
giant network and um
and you're trying to have your
comparative competitive comparative
advantage so what's your comparative
advantage
yeah i would say that my job is to be
the very best partner for a super
ambitious founder in the zero to one
phase
so right like if you look at my podcast
people say hey why don't you have this
guest why don't you have that guest
but starting greatness is all about zero
to one
awesome startup super ambitious what was
it like before they succeeded
and there's power there's addition and
subtraction
you know like sometimes uh by saying
what you're not for
but like niching down you're very
powerful to the people who care about
your niche
because people say where have you been
all my life and so what you're trying to
do is find that set of
like-minded co-conspirators for the
niche that you've really
chosen to be great at and and not get
preoccupied with the fact that you can't
do it all
right you're you're way better off
understanding
what you can just stick the landing at
and and and and develop your talent so
you can do it even better and better
through time
and today floodgate is more like a
traditional firm right it's like a
company
kind of like let's say current world
slash old world right you have a
you have a brand you have multiple
employees uh you have a central fund
you have your lp base it's sort of
static and then you're investing in a
specific
let's say set a criteria of of companies
um
whereas the way you're describing things
it sort of feels like if
correct me if i'm wrong it sort of
sounded like in the future what my
you 20 years from now what you might
have done instead of set up floodgate is
you would have set up
i don't know um you know a one-person
investing fund
uh yourself or like a dow or something
like that
basically a trust that's going to invest
in a whole bunch of things on the
network
and um and you wouldn't need the
structure of
of a fund with employees with all these
different things so would you
if you didn't have this already set up
and you were setting it up for the next
20 years would you have set up
your investing differently than you did
with a kind of traditional vc fund
well i i like the way we're set up
because i think that when you're
when you're investing in these crazy
risky startups too early way too early
or legally ambiguously too early
uh it's good to have friends and it's
good to have people to
run ideas by but we have a very i i'm
not saying
i'm not sure our point of view works for
everybody so
i don't even think a startup is a
company right so i think a startup is
the the capabilities and talents of the
founders and
their insight about the future and what
you're what you're betting is on two
things one is that their insights right
and two
is they're good enough to navigate the
idea to a great product someday but like
lyft started a zim ride and twitter they
couldn't decide whether to call it
voicemail 2.0 or
twtr twitch started as justin.tv
octa started as sasher and so like what
do you do with the fact that
90 of your profits come from things that
started out different
and so my my theory on that is the way
to succeed is to realize that a startup
isn't a company at all
and that it's it's the insights and the
founders and you're
you you make fun of your ability to
predict what they're going to come up
with that
is false precision to even try but
instead where you should be precise is
can these people do the job and
uh is this is this a powerful enough
breakthrough
insight you um you i believe it's your
partner
i looked up who the top venture
capitalists were i think it was your
partner what's your what's her name
uh ann miraco yeah yes and is uh
i looked at like cb insights 2020 2019
2018 2017.
i think she was in the top 10 sometimes
number two or three in many many many of
the years
um consistently you just showed me a
sign or a a thing of dollar bills with
steve blank you know who's like
godfather of silicon valley saying
everything mike does
turns into money you uh i wish what
what makes you guys great what makes you
able to spot these interesting
opportunities
i think that uh you know it's funny if
you if you had
say um warren buffett uh
on your show or you know you've had stan
drunken miller before
on your show right and um when they talk
about investments
you'll probably notice they talk about a
few things what's the operating history
of the organization what is their
competitive moat
uh you know they have a set of factors
you know um
that cause them to think that a company
is a good investment or not
um what's interesting is in our world
none of those mental models apply and so
because a startup's not a company
there is no operating history there
there's no moat they don't even have a
product yet they got no customers
and so what i think we're better at than
most
is a understanding that's true and b
then asking okay so what should the
mental models be
right if if charlie munger and warren
buffett have 90 mental models
and they don't apply to startup
investing well what are the mental
models for startup investing then
and so we've spent years right just
being
students of that question and you know
we probably got about 30 or so
that we've developed but we try to we
try to
evaluate the startup through the lens of
those mental models
rather than make the mistake of thinking
that a startup is a re-hosted company
it's not one or two of those mental
models that we wouldn't expect
right like uh you know i might expect
somebody to say
you know we want to be in a uh a big
market with customers who really love
your products like okay yeah great you
know um
we want to be growing you know extremely
fast exponential growth well yeah
it's obvious at that point i also enjoy
checkmate uh so so what's a what's a
mental model that's
not so obvious where 100 people in a
room would nod their heads and
immediately say i already do that i
already think that way when i when it
comes to investing for me
yeah so i'll just give a few examples
you know so i'd say
at a meta level we have a set of mental
models about founding teams
and then we have a set of mental models
about insights
and um founding team a good example
would be
um jazz band and not a marching band
so in companies you have org charts you
have people who want
cheap music and dance steps and if you
don't give that to them
the organization is going to be a
chaotic mess and all screwed up and
discombobulated
in a startup it's more like when you go
to the french quarter
and you watch a jazz band there the guy
the lead goes on riff and everybody else
just
goes with it and you'll never hear that
tune the same way ever again
but everybody knows that that's what
they're in it for and nobody's saying
hey that's not on my sheet music you
didn't say that was going to happen
right that's that's the way they like to
um offer their art to the world
and so i like to say when a when a
startup starts it goes through this
breakthrough sequence it has to have a
great insight
which is something about the future
that's not obvious that most people
don't know
and then after that they have to create
a product breakthrough where they get
product market fit and zero to one
and then they have to have a growth
breakthrough where they get escape
velocity
and then and only then do they earn the
right to someday be in the pantheon of
companies
but it's but it's wrongheaded to give
startup founders
big company advice at any of those
stages in fact all of those stages are
different it would be bad to give
growth advice to an insight developer
for example because it would be
precisely wrong
uh so that would be an example on the
team side uh to me the
um on the inside perspective it would be
don't be market first because there is
no market yet
and so rather than trying to think of a
startup market
we want to arrive at startup markets by
following inflections
we want to we want to say okay the cost
of an ai prediction
is going down exponentially how is power
going to shift in the industry because
of that
and like what what new markets might
arise that had never existed before
these inflections they they power your
why now
so like um with lyft um gps has got
included for free in smartphones
and we believe that everybody's gonna
have smartphones someday even though in
2010 only 10 did so you could say wow
now i can see a world in the future
where drivers and riders will be able to
locate each other on a network
and ever and there will be a network
effect because there'll be all these
people have these phones
you could have been right about that
before then but you would have still
failed
because you wouldn't have enough people
with the phones and they wouldn't have
been able to find each other
and so i'd say that's the other
counter-intuitive thing is that
you can't you can't look at the
company's tangible operating history
because there is none
what you have to do instead is imagine a
world where
their inflections change the future in a
dramatic way
and that that you know change the rules
and like all the stuff that people think
is going to happen
something very radically different is
going to happen and why do i believe
this entrepreneur
what what is it that they've discovered
about the world that could cause me to
take that bet
what you're describing is is awesome and
it's like
but but it's it's a it's a narrow
it's a narrow but wonderful outlook so
what you're describing
about inflections and looking at the
world in 20 years is definitely about
disruption and these are things that are
this is what allows an uber or an airbnb
to go from not even an idea to a small
idea to a
50 to 100 billion dollar company these
are like truly disruptive and
transformative things
but then on the other side there's like
on the podcast actually aired today sean
interviewed this guy named brian
who owns 100 of 1-800 got junk
their revenue might be four or 500
million dollars and he owns all of it so
he
who knows he's probably worth two or
three billion dollars and has
probably a pretty calm life and he's not
doing anything
probably probably innovative at all i
mean maybe there's like micro
innovations like you know our supply
chain is a little bit interesting or
the way that we dispatch people is a
little bit interesting or
or it could just be operational
excellence meaning our website ranks
number one
or uh we know how to get email right
yeah speller name cute brand how do you
um so like your your what we just
discussed was far on one end do you
ever look at the other side or or
for your job do you only care about one
side and maybe you just like to
for shoot the or talk to your
friends who want to get wealthy do you
say like yeah but this side's actually
kind of interesting too yeah and it's
funny because we alluded to this earlier
um i don't try to be for everybody
uh i try to be the the very best at the
thing i try to be good at
and so my view is that
i want to go very focused on
breakthrough startups and in that zero
to one phase and how they
so i like to say i'm a rocket fuel
salesman
and i go i go to founders and i say
don't take my fuel
if you don't want to achieve escape
velocity with that rocket that's on the
launch pad
because if you're not sure it's a rocket
this fuel isn't going to be good for
your vehicle
right on your scooter right and so like
i probably don't deserve too much credit
when it does escape
but i probably don't deserve too much of
the blame when it doesn't right
i'm just like just be clear about what
i'm selling here
and and people say well you know it's
not realistic that
um that everybody should build uh one of
the 20 billion dollar plus exit startups
of the year and i'm like
and you're you're correct about that
like i'm not saying that
my advice or my approach is mainstream
or even normal
in fact i would say it's hyper not
normal but like
but in that area in that area of i sell
rocket fuel to people who want to blast
their rockets into outer space and get
escape velocity
i try to be the very best period and so
like that's that's what i'm in it for so
a lot of your listeners might be like oh
that's interesting and
kind of intellectually interesting but
i'm not i'm not one of those
but that's okay there's lots of ways to
get rich in this world and there's lots
of
lots of ways to succeed in business
every it comes back to
everybody should know what's my
comparative advantage and
not be preoccupied by all the things you
can't be the best at so you're not even
close to the guy who sees like oh wow
there's um
a ton of really poorly run laundry
stores or laundry mats we should buy all
of them and put a back-end software i
mean that doesn't even kind of closely
uh or that doesn't even even get you
excited well
not only that like if somebody said hey
can you give me some advice on how to
grow this i would say
you should not listen to me i don't know
what i'm talking about i don't know how
to do laundromats at scale
like it's it's not even a question
whether i'm interested it's a question
whether i'm competent
uh and i'm not i'm like i'm not and i
don't try to be
and i i let go of the idea that i need
to be
you that i love i love your answer by
the way uh i have
something to say about that too but i
would say like
you know you've made me realize that i
think one of the things that we're we're
trying to build our comparative
advantages is like
um we could have this we get on this
podcast twice a week and we shoot the
either just me and sam or
bring a great guest like you on and we
talk about everything from i think one
of the most popular episodes was
um you know biology talking about like
the future of startups our cities
and it's like wait what and you know
biology will will bend your brain with
the blockchain
and then uh the next episode so he's
probably the most listened to and the
second most listed too is
this side hustle this entrepreneur has
where he's we break down his business of
vending machines he's got 27 vending
machines
he's making six figures of profit and
you know he got started with very little
capital and it
doesn't take rocket science or rocket
fuel to do it and our listeners
like the um the breadth of that uh how
we can hop from
blue collar we have a segment called the
hillbilly side hustle
which is like you know just a blue
collar kind of like simple thing you can
do
all the way to okay what is you know
some disruptive idea
how does ai impact the space and is it
okay if we talk about biology for a
minute because i think he's like
amazing and he's crazy yeah so so like
um
you know earlier i mentioned this idea
of cloud culture
i think biology probably has the best
handle on this
of anybody i talk to so like and and you
know i've listened to much of what he
said but like what i think
happens at the limit is that all of
these different cloud cultures
are like their own societies yep and so
right now the main main organizing
principle of society is the nation state
which is also an economies of scale
centric model right but if you think
about it what is bitcoin really
bitcoin is a society of people who care
about sound money
and the protocol is what enables
governance and so
these societies at the limit i think
look more and more like the future
version of countries
right you know what is a country really
it's a bunch of people who decide what
their boundaries are
who decide who gets in the club and they
have a constitution where they decide
how to separate powers and how to
protect the rights of individuals
against
the mob and the tyrant um that's exactly
what bitcoin does
with its protocol and just to use some
other examples so bitcoin is the people
who
have this you know cult-like belief
religious belief around sound money
ethereum is people who believe in
programmable money and then you have
wall street bets which is like hey
let's just middle finger to you know uh
to the large
you know to the incumbents so how does
you know david beat goliath and we're
gonna
we're basically gonna screw around with
them and make profits while we do it
that's what we're here for
uh and we will we will assign ourselves
names you know they call themselves
retards and things like that because in
their culture that's okay right
yeah burning man is a pop-up culture
that happens for a week in the desert
where all these people will go behave
totally differently than they will the
other 51 weeks out of the year
and so there's a whole bunch of these
either pop-up cultures cloud cultures
that all have different
different virtues different uh
admissions criteria and
and all the different pieces you just
described yeah and it's so interesting
because it there's historical parallels
right like in the
in the reformation uh the pope used to
declare all the answers and then all of
a sudden the printing press comes out in
double entry accounting
and now martin luther can distribute the
bible to lots of people
uh with in a permissionless way
ironically
and then not only that the merchants of
venice can trade with each other without
a central authority because they can
have
double entry records and keep track of
ious
and so to me like the internet and
blockchain are just so amazingly
parallel
to that and i think society ebbs and
flows it's like
when you're too decentralized for too
long it's chaotic
and so then then you have innovations
that centralize the means of production
but then it gets too centralized and so
what we're seeing now i believe is wall
street bets perfect example
the people at the edge are saying the
network should decide not the center
and if you read books like revolt to the
republic and things like that
you see a world where the people at the
edge are starting to say about the
people at the center
you're illegitimate just like people at
the edge back in the reformation started
to say that about
the the pope and some of the things that
were happening
with um exclusionary you know sort of
insider only activities and so
in the last two years you know social
media went from
you know the edge to call it pointing at
mainstream media mainstream media now is
like synonymous with the with fake news
right that wasn't even a thing five
years ago right
um mainstream media is now used as a
derogatory description of something
which is kind of crazy right that's a
big change
and the important thing is like i try
not to be too judgmental about it so i
don't sit there and say oh those
mainstream media people are no good i'm
just like
it's inevitable that media is going to
decentralize
it's inevitable that money will it's
inevitable that politics will it's
inevitable
that a lot of these things will and it's
like arguing for it or against it's kind
of like arguing against the direction of
the wind it's it's just
it's it's fruit but but then back to the
your listeners
to me what that means writ large is if
the 20th century was about being
the quote-unquote organization man and
following the rules and progressing up
the hierarchy
it doesn't exist anymore now you have to
be
you have to take agency for your own
life
and own your comparative advantage and
understand that that is your
responsibility as a free person
in this world and if you do that you're
going to be
incredibly rewarded in the 21st century
but if you wish
that it's like the 20th i got bad news
for you it's not going to be
floodgate invested into refinery29 right
yeah um for those we have unfortunately
or i mean it is what it is a lot of our
listeners are men so they don't know
refinery 29 is a huge media company
geared for women
refinance29.com they were pretty big
right they uh were like maybe 200
million dollars or 150 million dollars
in revenue
and then they sold or merged or
something like that with vice right
yes um and vice is like a probably a
billion dollar a year entity at this
point
with everything they have going on do
you think that media companies like that
given what you're saying about i mean
because devices at this point even
though they were new
vice and refinery 29 are probably almost
like old school at this point
do you think that those style of media
companies are still going to be great
companies given what you've just said
well i think that there's going to be a
very rich ecosystem of all types of
media companies
but but to me the defining new
characteristic will be
that media is no longer a function of
the credential elites telling you what
to think
and uh that that was the real problem
that we started to get in the media in
my opinion is that
um you you had a set of credential
elites
running these media companies of which
there weren't very many
and um these institutions are all
inherited now
rather than founded and so the people
running these institutions didn't really
understand what made them great in the
old days
and so they they started to get worse
over time in their effectiveness and
legitimacy
and so to me the real question about
media is not so much
is there one way it's going to happen
versus not i think that the winners will
be those
that um niche down have a comparative
advantage in the type of content that
they cover
and attract uh the attention of the
people who care about that type of
content
and and the credentials won't define it
because
um the the old media companies had
credentialed elites running them but
they also had a monopoly on distribution
with the newspaper and how they how they
got print
magazines out and things like that so i
think that all of that's going to change
is there any media companies or um
opportunities that you're looking at and
you're like oh that's kind of
interesting for us
i would i would say that my colleague
ann miraco is
probably smarter about that than i am
you know i and it's funny even within
floodgate i tend to stick to
my areas that i'm excited about and i um
so there's a lot of exciting things that
i'll
that i'll miss probably um but i'll ask
you a question
yeah i'm gonna ask you a question that
might be hard to answer
because it's one of those things like oh
you know how how are you you
but you um you've said a couple things
that caught my attention
you know you have these nice phrases so
one is i didn't realize that
i see this on your bio here i didn't
realize you coined the term thunder
lizards i've heard
many investors talk about thunder
lizards that's something they want to
invest in
which is like sort of like you know the
godzilla type companies that emerge
every decade or so
and like that's what you really chase
because those are where all the returns
are
and those are what change the world um
but you also said the
kind of the rock i'm a rocket fuel
salesman
you are catchier than your average vc
you are
uh more i don't know you have you have a
little sort of
gift there of coining these little mind
viruses these little little phrases that
stick with people rather than just
saying
a bunch of jargon um is that a skill you
learned consciously or is that just
you know growing up your parents talk
like that where'd that come from
uh i don't know but i guess the the way
i look at things in this world is
you want to force a choice and not a
comparison
and and so like what do i mean by that
like like yeah you just did it again you
did it again yeah exactly
right so so like like if i say hey
we're investing in particularly
disruptive types of companies
that's not the same as saying thunder
lizards right and so
why is it so important well if you're
trying to create a breakthrough
by definition it breaks free from the
present so by definition it can't be
compared to something in the present
uh because if it's comparable to what's
in the present it's too incremental it's
too conventional
and so like when i say force of choice
and not comparison i said i say to
founders
if let's say everybody's selling banana
you can't say i'm
a 5x better banana you instead you
should come out and say i'm an apple
and not everybody's gonna want your
apple but a hundred percent of the
people who prefer
apples are gonna want what you have and
like forget the guy who wants the
best banana there's a thousand of those
people you need to waste not an erg of
energy on them you need to
spend your time on the people who
potentially value your advantage and
start a movement
around that you know earlier we talked
about markets companies have markets
that could be segmented sub segmented
and classified
startups don't startups they create
movements
they create they have a secret about the
future they get early believers
who co-conspire with them to create a
co-create a different future
and the market emerges as a consequence
of the movement succeeding
but in the early days we just have to
get people moving we have to get people
moving
to somewhere different not better and so
as a result we must
force a choice and not a comparison and
as a seed investor i have to do the same
thing because there's 2 000 seed funds
now
and so it was innovative when and i
helped invent seed investing in
2006 but like now there's 2 000 firms
and so we have to come up with some way
for people to say okay i can't reconcile
the choice of working with floodgate
versus
brand x um
right writing checks with writing checks
on the spot that's how we differentiate
well i don't know but i think there's a
lot to be it's it relates to niching
down i think a lot of people would
benefit from the idea
of how can i force a choice and not a
comparison it takes more courage
and it forces you to say no to more than
you say yes to
but if you if you do it the right way
the stuff you say yes to
i like to say it's less but better is
the way to think about it
you've uh you've had some amazing people
in your podcast you've
invested in a ton of amazing companies
and i bet you know just about everyone
in this world
of all these people that you've invested
in or or did business with
if you guys were put on a on a stranded
island who do you think would come out
on top
who's the most formidable person that
you've uh you've worked with
oh there have been so many great people
um
i think a lot of it would be a function
of just uh who had the right idea at the
right time you know so much of this is
just
i call it a founder future fit it's just
like
you know like when it when andreessen
did mozilla
it was just he was the perfect person in
the world at the perfect time to do that
idea
and so you know it's not just how
formidable is the person but it's also
just
was it was the timing right and were
they just the right person the right
time but i'm i'm um
i'm obsessed with stories and i love
interesting personality types is there
anyone that fits that bill of
of being incredibly formidable like to
the point of like you you think how can
you be more like that person or
or i wish everyone thought a little bit
more like this person yeah
yeah so i i try to learn from everybody
but i not never try to imitate or be
like somebody else
because then that that that defeats the
purpose i'm that now i'm comparing
myself to somebody else
and so i never do that uh i don't
believe that people should compare
themselves with anybody i think they
should learn from people
but i don't think they should compare
themselves to others and i don't think
they should have heroes and
i think that yeah you mentioned a couple
people that you've learned from
uh you know biology being one um
you know tim ferriss that he learned
from you who are some other names you
know if if people listen to this and
they're like you know or me right i
really enjoyed hearing you talk during
this hour
uh i think you got a bunch of smart
ideas i want to know
you know what's he eating basically
what's your information diet what are
what are your
sort of some of your favorite people to
follow and learn from that you're
getting a bunch of interesting
information that's not
just like the rest yeah so um
well i like that the farm street blog a
lot uh with shane parish and
and uh and by the way just because i
don't invest like buffett and monger
doesn't mean i don't study them like
crazy right because i think
that when i when i read how they look at
the world
i'll understand what's different about
how they look at the world but i'll also
connect dots that will make the
difference of my world more clear
i read a ton i probably read about one
or two books a week
just in general um what are some of the
ones i've
read recently that i liked one i like a
lot it's called the courage to be
disliked
uh by a couple of japanese authors i
think it's
it's amazing and so then i went down
this rabbit hole of
the the psychiatrist uh alfred adler who
who kind of came of age at the same time
as
freud and young but uh wasn't as famous
but i think he's
i think that alfred adler's ideas about
individual agency are perfectly timed
for the 21st century
uh so i've been liking uh everything
that i can get my hands on about him
um and it's and it's weird because
although i read a lot of books
there's there's always a subset that i
come back to over and over again where i
try to
take notes and because i try to i try to
make sure i really understand it so that
i could explain it to somebody else in a
really clear way
uh so i so i liked the courage to be
disliked quite a bit
uh i've been reading a lot of stuff on
stoicism lately
uh which i find to be very misunderstood
um but you know what's the
misunderstanding
i think that most people think of stoics
as uh you know
uh emotionless uh turn the other cheek
when things go bad
and i actually find that when you read
about the stoics and
that there are actual philosophies in
this world they're actually
quite optimistic and quite inspiring and
i find that uh
it's helpful for me to um internalize
so like things like some of the lessons
of stoicism and some of the
lessons of alfred adler all find myself
reading those books over and over again
and and trying to make the list of
things to learn and
ask myself every day am i am i
exercising those muscles
and then there will be other things
where i'm like a friend of mine i'll say
this is a really good book i'm like i
should just read that
so right you know that's just fun it's
great all right we're coming up on the
hour so we can we can wrap it
um mike thanks for joining this is great
where do people find you if they want to
get more so obviously the podcast
uh so starting greatness where else
should they follow to get more
yeah i'm on twitter or at m2jr uh
let's see where that's probably the best
place yeah or floodgate.com
you're you're a tweeting machine i've
been following you since uh i talked to
him years ago about you okay yeah
and and if you guys want to cover any
other topics happy to i know that we
kind of
bounced around so uh i want the american
next i feel like that would have been an
interesting one that i think we should
we if you're up for we could do a round
two around
american nationalities i think there's a
bunch that's there that that
people are talking a ton about yeah in
all these themes right like i think that
the idea
also of uh you know blockchains and sort
of thinking about um
the the future of money and how we're
going to a currency governed by commons
rather than
fiat government is interesting i think
that
you know the evolution of you know i
like to say that computing
uh phases you had mainframes and you had
pcs and you had internet and they always
start with an enabling technology and
they commoditize the prior so
mainframes computers were expensive and
then
pcs computers were basically free
proprietary software becomes valuable
okay next thing the internet
software becomes open source amassing
lots of proprietary data becomes
valuable
and so one way i look at blockchains are
they're the next wave of computing
and that they're going to probably
democratize data
and control uh of things back to
networks
and then what becomes a valuable thing
my instinct is it's about governance
and so there's there's like a lot of
conversation we could have about that
that might be interesting and then
i totally agree uh america next all the
stuff that i think is gonna have to
happen and for
the military to be more agile and uh for
us to kind of
upgrade our thinking about stuff you
know when you're talking
i'm like this is what i could be like if
i could just focus on three things that
i really believed in
and i just stopped thinking about other
for like two years
i could have this level of clarity and
uh and insight and
you're making me want to focus which sam
and many others in my life have ever
have tried to get me to focus before and
uh this may be the
the most effective way well there's no
one way right
like i like to be people are like a t
right it's like uh
you want to be a mile wide an inch deep
so that you just
can appropriate creative ideas from the
world but then i think you want to be a
mile deep
somewhere right so it's like a t right
and it's like
that's why you read several books at a
time but then you also go deep on a
small number they're truly great
do you um who who should we invite next
on this podcast who do you think is some
of the some some of the are some of the
best storytellers and prolific idea
folks
you had reid hoffman we're trying to get
in touch with him is there anyone else
that you think is is
we should invite you reed hoffman naval
ravikant
um you know chris sacca
is always a good storyteller um
i can think about that you know the
instagramers are fun
uh andy radcliffe probably not as famous
as some
some of your guests and stuff but boy is
he a clear thinker
uh a great communicator what's the best
way to get in touch with reid
just to call emily you think probably uh
let's see
um um or you just say that i've
mentioned
you guys and that it was a good show and
then i enjoyed it
the people that you just mentioned i'll
email the people you just mentioned
and i'll say mike said you're the mike
said you're the guy
yeah i'll just still you know i haven't
seen as much of chris sacca lately so i
don't know if
that would be as effective with him but
uh but i think that uh some of the other
guys would
would uh would recognize me pretty well
i showed up for chris
one morning he texted me said hey i
gotta film a shark tank intro we need
some bodies in the background
uh to for my my intro and i i left my
job i went to
where he was at nine in the morning and
i filmed a uh
i was a body double i was i was an extra
in the background for his
shark tank intro so i'll pull that
favorite card and be like hey chris
now's the time to pay it back yeah if
you haven't had mark cuban
i think he's really good uh um
and and by the way on this so it's funny
because you guys are using zencaster um
so does shane harris so i was on his uh
sorry shane parish
and on his um after he listened to the
to the talk he's like there's so many up
front questions i wish i'd asked you
uh can we do this again and so i was
like sure so we ended up having a lot of
content that he kind of
cut down but like if if you find
yourself in that position here let me
know i'm happy to uh
help you make it is bet you know less
but better right so if we can
right you know if we're we're gonna ship
a product it might as well be
awesome
right so i love you
where are you from i was born in
oklahoma but
moved all around because my dad was an
ibm yeah and then
worked at microsoft yeah i feel like um
how old how old are you
uh early 53. yeah so you're i'm i'm 31
so you would have had to have me when
you were quite young
but uh i feel like you could you could
you i could
you could be my uncle i think
that's what the founders call me their
nickname for me is the crazy uncle
so yeah yeah i think we kind of look the
same i can tell you
i thought you would have been from the
midwest or maybe the south i'm from
missouri
oh nice yep show me state yeah and uh my
cousins uh live in oklahoma and uh in
owens oklahoma where they buck bulls
um i i had a i have a feeling you and i
we could be distance
distant cousins so we don't even know it
yep yeah
you never know coming from missouri and
oklahoma you never know
yeah well i appreciate this man this is
awesome shawn you got anything to say
no my camera died i'm at the overheating
mark but uh
mike this is great thank you for coming
on i i enjoyed that that was good
and you're in austin uh now i live in
marin county so i'm
in northern california oh i thought you
lived in austin for some reason
no i i helped tim though find his place
so when he decided to move i
you know i used to live in austin about
up until about 15 years ago and my
family's from there all my relatives and
stuff and so you know
you did the opposite of what everyone
else did it it seems so and everybody
keeps asking me when are we going to
move back to austin i
you know i don't know i'm pretty happy
with where we live but you know it's
pretty crazy time so you never know
we'll see
well thanks for being here we'll talk
soon
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on a
road less travel never looking back